اعتقد ان اهم ما يركز عليه البنتون حاليا
في الحوارات اليوميه هو القاعده الصناعيه
الدفاعيه وصناعه الدفاع وقدرتها على انتاج
وصناعه تشكيله واسعه من القدرات المختلفه
من الدبابات والمدفعيه وصولا الى الطائرات
والقنابل فالاداره والبنتاجون قلقان بسبب
تركيز صناعه الدفاع الامريكيه على الكفاءه
وتحسين القيمه التي يحصل عليها كل دافع
ضرائب مقابل اموال الضرائب التي يدفعها
الا ان ما شاهدناه في اوكرانيا اثبت ان
خوض الحروب المفاجئه والعنيفه يستهلك
كميات كبيره من المواد ووزاره الدفاع تشعر
بان الصناعه الامريكيه ليست لديها القدره
على الانتاج بالنطاق الذي ترغب به الوزاره
في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان الحرب في اوكرانيا وباشكال عديده
برهنت على صحه العديد من افكار الولايات
المتحده الاساسيه في الشؤون الامنيه
واستراتيجيتها العسكريه للعشرين او
الثلاثين عاما الماضيه وهنا تكمن قيمه
الاصدقاء والشركاء والعمل من خلال الدول
التي لديها توجهات متشابهه وفي مثالنا
الحالي تعمل الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في
النيتو عن قرب مع الاوكرانيين لمقاومه
الاعتداء الروسي واعتقد ان هذه المقاربه
اكدت الكثير من الاشياء التي تحدثت عنها
الاداره الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]